you know if there's one thing that i'm
uncomfortable with it's cooking
you can do it it's definitely not my
thing just make sure you season it
correctly okay see there we go you
already got me right
i love to cook i wouldn't say i love it
he actually made me gnocchi with sausage
and that was the only meal he really
ever cooked for me and it was a one-time
thing it was good though it was very
good it was very good let me throw this
bad boy on here
it's kind of hot
so do i have to season the other side
too yeah i would
you should have had me cook the steak we
kind of have like a little thing called
steak night and we'll cook them in
different cuts and different types drew
and i are apart a lot of time so i think
it's good for not only us to connect but
also for us to connect with our kids i
know that both of my kids really enjoy
having everyone at the table i feel like
we were raised that way just to be able
to carry that on with our kids is really
cool
wow yours is good
i know i don't cook that much but mine's
going to look way better than you want i
think i'm going to make mine look like a
500
you're going to make a five star i'm
going to make a six star you're awfully
confident babe
you got to be especially when you're
cooking good for us going against each
other is always going to be more
difficult we do have to live together
and we're both extremely competitive
she's extremely competitive
okay throw a little garnish on there
make it look pretty i see you you need
some help with that like i mean i'm good
at assisting people
hold on let me plate it a little lemon
next to it this is looking real
delicious
your shake looks solid a nice
temperature i see the juices looks very
tasty you did your thing
i think you did a great job i don't
think yours is better than mine but i'm
proud of how hard you try thank you
we cook maybe four nights a week what we
put in our body is really important
especially as elite athletes eating
sustainable foods is huge especially
with kids too we're very conscious of
what we put in their bodies as well and
even like my daughter you can tell the
difference between like good meat and
bad meat let's see how you did
wow i'm impressed that's really good can
i say it perform under pressure baby
it's like a six star restaurant
the salmon was amazing and it was just
salt and pepper on there i don't know if
it was the one who prepared it i'm sure
it's because again it was sustainable
and it was healthy it just tasted so
fresh and it was light
yeah that's what i'm talking about wow
did your thing on the steak thank you
it's nice and tender it's easy to cut
through it's like butter baby it's
really hard to get to the grocery store
especially with our hectic lifestyle
let's see what we got here having
butcher box and knowing that there's
going to be meat in the freezer it's a
huge relief for me to cook dinner
it's a nice meal just a little date
night action just us two so you're
saying we'll do it again yeah maybe next
time we can uh we can cook for our
friends and our family and they can
judge us do
you sound real confident when you said
that i am made me a little nervous